foreign
welcome back to Harry Potter Theory who
was more powerful Sirius Black or
Dolores Umbridge for those of us who
think this question has an obvious
answer we might blindly claim Sirius as
the mightier wizard but others who
consider this question carefully know
that it's not as simple as black and
white Sirius Black was one of the
greatest Duelists in the entire Order of
the Phoenix but Dolores Umbridge was a
cunning strategist and in her own way
was able to defeat even Albus Dumbledore
So today we're going to take a look at
these two prominent members of The
Wizarding World and figure out who was
more powerful how we'll do it now
whenever you compare Wizards and witches
to see who is more powerful there are a
few different ways to go about it we can
just stack up their list of dueling
opponents and see which one is defeated
the most powerful wizard or witch but
that doesn't quite capture a full
picture on the other side of the debate
we could just rifle through Cirrus
blacks and Dolores umbridge's
proficiency with spells and potions but
that too doesn't quite seem like enough
either to really get to the answer we're
going to take a holistic approach we'll
break down these two opponents in three
different categories one magical Feats
two dueling and three intangibles after
taking a look at each of these we should
be able to get to the bottom of this
matter and figure out who really was the
more powerful magic user between them
magical Feats when we look at Sirius
Black's magical feeds there's simply no
shortage of achievements to Marvel ants
ziris hails from one of the oldest pure
blood families in Britain and even
though Wizard's pureblood Heritage
didn't necessarily have any great
bearing on their magical abilities
Sirius was certainly steeped in magical
lore from an early age perhaps that's
what made him such a great member of the
Marauders a group of four young Hogwarts
friends who were all equally obsessed
with perfecting spells and disrupting
classes Sirius became an accomplished
transfigurationist when he was just a
teenager a skilled potioneer by just his
fifth year in Hogwarts and even helped
to construct the Marauders map which had
become the basis for many of Harry
Potter's adventures in the decades that
followed but sirius's greatest magical
feat was certainly his escape from
Azkaban that horrid prison inhabited by
the soul-leating Dementors had never
lost an inmate in a breakout and until
bharti Crouch Jr was revealed to be
alive and well Sirius Black was the very
first one in all of recorded history but
the simple fact that he escaped Azkaban
is somehow the least interesting part of
it because he did so with relative ease
even though he had been prison for over
a decade and had ample time to
transfigure into his animagus form black
had never tried to use it to escape with
only a thought black was able to
transform into a black dog and since he
never registered that skill with the
ministry of magic none of the Dementors
or other Ministry officers would have
known the menji mat was actually Sirius
Black so using his skills in
Transfiguration black simply changed
into his animagus and walked out of
Azkaban and swam across the sea to the
mainland and when we turn our attention
to Dolores umbridge's magical feeds
we'll find an equally impressive
although less bombastic list of
achievements in hindsight after Umbridge
was locked away for good many of the
Wizards and witches of Harry Potter's
generation looked back on umbrage with
disdain and for good reason she was an
absolute Tyrant during her time at
Hogwarts and tortured the students at
every child she had but Harry and his
peers dislike from bridge has led to the
rise of a rumor that she wasn't a very
great witch which isn't entirely Fair
she was one of the highest ranking
members of the ministry of magic and in
time the headmistress of Hogwarts I'm
sure when compared to other professors
at the school like Minerva McGonagall or
Severus Snape
Umbridge wasn't up to snuff but Snape
and McGonagall were among the greatest
Wizards and witches of the entire
Century so holding umbrage next to them
isn't giving her a fair Shake if we set
our sights a little bit lower and
measure Umbridge fairly we'll find that
she was a decent witch in her own right
she created the black quill which was
able to painfully carve words into the
tomb of students hands and her use of
the fire making spell and shield spell
certainly didn't make her look like a
subpar wedge as she used them in combat
and classroom management but her
greatest feat was her ability to
weaponize Dementors she set them loose
on Harry and dursley which put Hogwarts
on a course for the eventual dismissal
of Albus Dumbledore even though the
ministry of magic had a system for
controlling Dementors one that remains a
mystery until this day it was rare for
an individual to utilize Dementors on
their own and not only did Dolores
Umbridge do that but she managed to
weaponize the Dementors without letting
too many other members of the ministry
in on her plan dueling but let's take a
step away from their magical Feats and
look at their dueling skills we'll start
with Sirius Black again because he is
the longest and perhaps most impressive
record when it comes to Dueling this era
the greatest combatants were either
members of the Order of the Phoenix or
members of the Death Eaters
sure there were professional Duelists
all around the globe but their Jewels
had rules judges and a strict system
when the Order of the Phoenix went to
war against Voldemort both sides knew
the death was a certain possibility
and even after being imprisoned for over
a decade the experience from his time in
the Order of the Phoenix served Sirius
Black yet again the battle of the
Department of Mysteries black easily
defeated Antonin dolahov in their fight
and immediately after pushed Bellatrix
Lestrange to the absolute Brink
during that final fight when Sirius
Black fought his cousin one-on-one black
couldn't help but gloat at his obvious
superiority in dueling but that brief
moment of arrogance would cost him his
life as a spell from bellatrix's wand
caught black Square in his chest and
pushed him through the Gateway of death
again after taking a look at Sirius
Black's accomplishments and his failed
it's hard to look at Dolores umbridge's
without seeing an obvious Gap unlike
Sirius Black Umbridge never spent her
childhood getting into fights with her
fellow witches and wizards as a member
of the Marauders black would regularly
stomp around the grounds of Hogwarts and
stir up travel with other children like
an unwitting Severus Snape although
those years in school might have seemed
like misguided youth or Worse bullying
Sirius Black certainly earned enough
experience to make him a decent duelist
by his seventh year and once he joined
to the Order of the Phoenix his
abilities only improved but Umbridge as
we've already stated didn't have the
same upbringing and she simply doesn't
have the same level of dueling opponents
in her past besides her one attempt to
defeat Albus Dumbledore in a duel there
actually isn't much that we can go by
she was obviously quite skilled with
Transfiguration unlike Sirius Black who
used that craft to conjure an animagus
unbridged used Transfiguration for her
typical darker form of magic she could
use her expertise to cast the
incarcerous spell which she used to
nearly murder a centaur in the Forbidden
Forest conjuration is a skill reserved
for the most talented witches and
wizards if she used similarly Sinister
magic during a jewel against Sirius
blank or another witch or wizard then
she could very well surprise them and
capture a victory
intangibles when we look at Sirius Black
and Dolores Umbridge it's not as simple
as their spell work or their dueling
skills there's a greater element of
intangibles the things that simply
weighed or measured and that's where
Dolores Umbridge seems to excel because
for Sirius Black his magical abilities
are all pretty straightforward he uses
them directly in combat against the dark
Wizards serving the Lord Voldemort
Dolores Umbridge is rarely that direct
she uses her magic to serve a simple end
her own rise through the politics of The
Wizarding World and in that Pursuit she
rarely seemed to abuse her magical
powers when she wanted to impose her
will on other teachers at Hogwarts she
didn't use her wand to do so she
artfully maneuvered the ministry of
magic to defeat faculty members on her
behalf and when she wanted to Target
troubled students she didn't suddenly
round them up with a great show of
forceful magic like a proper dark wizard
would instead Like a Surgeon she used
her own dark Creations like the black
quill or the occasional use of the
cruciatus curse to impose her will and
while Dolores Umbridge might not have
wowed anyone with her use of magic she
certainly got what she wanted she Rose
through the ranks of the ministry all
the way to the very top by Voldemort's
time all of that despite the fact that
her father was a humble janitor at the
ministry a fact that would have made any
other ambitious Ministry worker the
subject of non-stop ridicule but
Umbridge never allowed it and in all
likelihood disposed of those who even
attempted to make fun of her Heritage
Umbridge also had the rarest theme of
being a witch who defeated Dumbledore
again not through the ways you might
have expected but that doesn't really
matter in the end Umbridge found a way
de deliberately or through luck to
unseat Alba's Dumbledore as Headmaster
something that Voldemort couldn't even
do and to be completely honest something
at Voldemort didn't have the patience to
figure out conclusion so when we finally
try to answer this question who was more
powerful Sirius Black or Dolores
Umbridge I think the answer lies with
you what do you value more in your
wizard if you prefer a duelist who could
take on almost anyone in a fair fight
and come out the Victor then you'd
probably think Sirius Black was the more
powerful wizard but if you're a bit more
holistic and think about what either one
was able to achieve you might be
surprised by the fact that Umbridge did
so much I know I was personally I'm
giving it to Umbridge and that's it for
this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember if
you want to know what a man's like take
a good look at how he treats his
inferiors not his equals
[Music]
thank you